on a une plan on a lancé pour montrer
comment on peut défendre les droits des
travailleurs et travailleuses jaune
meeting veut entre autres faire passer
le salaire minimum fédéral à 20 $
l'heure
jobintree
est-ce que ça toucherait un grand nombre
de canadiens
[Musique]
la réponse est non
les travailleurs qui sont régis par le
code canadien du travail dans les
banques le secteur aérien ou les
télécommunications par exemple sont
somme toute peu nombreux ils
représentent 8% la main d'oeuvre au pays
en décembre prochain et le salaire
minimum fédéral va passer à 15 $ l'heure
ça permettra seulement à 26000 personnes
d'avoir une augmentation de salaire
combien seraient touchés s'il passe à 20
$ l'heure on n'a pas la réponse exacte
mais selon les dernières données de 2015
les trois quarts des employés assujettis
aux normes fédérales gagnait déjà plus
de 20 $ l'heure dans le secteur privé
9h20 - jésus price et charlie
chaplin pour jack meeting augmenter le
salaire minimum fédéral c'est une façon
de montrer l'exemple un travailleur sur
dix gagne le salaire minimum au pays
mais la phase de majorité d'entre eux
sont sous réglementation provinciale et
travaille par exemple dans le commerce
au détail et la restauration
c'est au nunavut que le salaire minimum
est le plus élevé à 16 $ l'heure et
parmi les provinces c'est en
colombie-britannique à 15 dollars 20 il
est de 14 et 25 en ontario 13 et 50 au
québec et le salaire minimum le plus
faible et en saskatchewan à 11 dollars
45 sur cet enjeu c'est davantage les
provinces peuvent changer les choses